Thanks to Great Courses Plus for supporting PBS.
Imagine there are two brands of the same product
that are almost identical in quality, but
one costs 3,000 times more than the other…
which do you buy?
Not exactly a brain-buster, I know, but millions
of Americans fail this test every day.
What is this exotic product with the power
to warp people’s financial sense beyond
recognition?
Water.
According to the EPA, the average price of
tap water in America is approximately $2 per
1,000 gallons.
Which means that a 16 oz. glass of water will
run you about 3 hundredths of a cent--and
it’s delivered right into your house, on
demand, 24 hours a day.
So how did it become reasonable--fashionable,
even--to buy the same product at prices higher
than milk or gasoline?
Since the early 20th century, when advances
in engineering and chemistry enabled cities
to process and distribute safe, clean drinking
water to millions of residents, bottled water
has been seen primarily as an indulgence of
wealthy elites.
However, in the last couple decades, bottled
water has had a remarkable resurgence, thanks
largely to rising concerns over the health
risks of sugary drinks.
As sales of Coke and Pepsi have declined,
these companies are trying to make up the
difference by encouraging consumers to buy
bottled water as a healthy alternative.
And it’s working.
In 1975, the average American only drank about
a gallon and a half of bottled water a year.
Today, that figure is around 30 gallons!
In 2016, sales of bottled water surpassed
even soda, but tap water remains bottled water’s
biggest competitor, with a price advantage
that seems hard to beat.
So bottlers’ marketing strategy is to present
their product as safer, tastier, and more
convenient.
But is it?
Municipal systems typically draw their water
from sources like wells, rivers, lakes, and
reservoirs.
Chemicals are added that bond with dirt and
particles which settle at the bottom of the
tank.
The water is then filtered through sand, gravel
and charcoal, and one last round of chemicals
is added--like chlorine to kill any remaining
parasites, and fluoride to prevent tooth decay.
Most systems are quality tested dozens of
times a day in accordance with the Safe Drinking
Water Act, and notwithstanding some recent
tragic contaminations, it’s considered to
be overwhelmingly safe.
So, where does bottled water come from?
Well, about a third of it comes from the same
place!
Many companies just fill their bottles from
municipal taps after a quick extra filtration.
After all, 90% of the treatment has already
been done by the city, and they’re selling
it for less than a penny a gallon!
The rest of bottled water comes from natural
sources like springs and groundwater, which
can be even cheaper, depending on local regulations.
In California, Nestlé pays the Forest Service
about $525 annually to extract over 30 million
gallons--which they will eventually sell for
192,000 times more!
While there are health and safety regulations
placed on the bottled water industry, they
are actually less stringent than municipal
ones.
Bottled water companies are typically allowed
to do most of their own testing, and unlike
municipal water systems, when they do find
contaminates, they’re often not forced to
do recalls or even alert the public.
If bottled water isn’t necessarily safer
than tap, what about the taste?
Well, this may depend on where you live.
Tap water in some cities, like Los Angeles,
tends to get poor scores on taste surveys,
even though tests show it to be as clean--or
cleaner--than bottled water.
New York’s tap water, on the other hand,
routinely beats the pants off bottled water
in blind taste tests.
The difference has less to do with quality
and more where it comes from and how it’s
treated.
Convenience outside of the house may be the
only contest that bottled water’s got locked up.
12 ounces of ice cold H2O prepackaged in a
lightweight container you can toss in a trash
can is definitely easier than hunting around
for a public water fountain.
But that convenience comes at a pretty steep
social cost.
About 3.8 million tons of plastic are used
to make water bottles every year, and only
a fraction of that gets recycled.
Manufacturing them uses the equivalent of
17 million barrels of oil and 3 times as much
water as actually goes into them.
All in all, it’s estimated that bottled
water takes about 2000 times more energy to
produce and distribute than tap water.
Now, there are some (rare) situations where
bottled water makes sense.
For instance, anytime a natural disaster compromises
municipal supplies, residents have no choice
but to rely on bottled water.
Besides, we drink way too much La Croix to
make any judgements.
Is it Croy?
I thought it was Cwah.
Cwah.
Croy.
La Croix.
Croix.
Not Croy.
Not Rue de la Croy.
Croix.
And if you’ve ever been told by your city
to boil your water before drinking, you know
that city water systems do sometimes fail
safety standards.
This can be caused by pollutants seeping into
the groundwater, or storms washing waste into
reservoirs, but the primary culprit is crumbling
infrastructure.
Most of the municipal water systems in the
U.S. were built about a hundred years ago,
and designed to last about a hundred years,
so today America has literally millions of
miles of water pipes that need fixing or replacing.
And with federal funding for infrastructure
at historically low levels, cities are scrambling
to find the money to do it.
That’s essentially what happened in Flint,
Michigan in 2014.
City officials tried to save money by switching
to a new water source, and then tried to save
more money by not using corrosion inhibitors
in the aging lead pipes.
Neurotoxic heavy metals seeped into the drinking
water, affecting hundreds of thousands of
residents.
Other cities are trying to avoid Flint’s
fate by raising rates to generate maintenance
funds, leading to an overall increase of 30%
in the average American water bill over the
last decade.
That’s a faster increase over inflation
than gasoline or groceries!
But even if you live in a place like Austin,
where water bills have skyrocketed over 150%
in recent years, it’s still much, much,
much cheaper than bottled water.
If you’re still worried about the safety
or flavor of your town’s water, you can
request a Water Quality Report from your water
company to find out where it comes from and
how its treated.
Or buy a simple water filter for your home
and a reusable bottle to carry with you, effectively
manufacturing the same product yourself that
sells in stores for thousands of times the
price.
The problem of how to deliver clean drinking
water to millions of consumers was effectively
solved a hundred years ago.
When you buy a bottle of water, you’re only
solving Coke’s problem of how to make up
for lagging soda sales.
And that’s our two cents!
Thanks to Great Courses Plus for supporting PBS.
The Great Courses Plus is a subscription on demand video learning service
with lectures and courses from professors from top universities and institutions.
Through your subscription, you get access to a library of lectures about anything that interests you...
science, math, history, literature, or even how to cook, play chess, or become a better photographer.
For example, in “Unexpected Economics,” you’ll learn the surprising ways that economic theory can shed a light on social phenomena
from traffic to crime to addiction.
To learn more, check out TheGreatCoursesPlus.com/twocents
or click on the link in the description below to start your trial today.
Thanks to our patrons for keeping Two Cents financially healthy.
Click the link in the description to become a Two Cents patron!